[Music]
three years ago we revolutionized
toilets with the intellicus 2000 but
today we're improving upon perfection I
give you bold shrine
[Applause]
say hello boltron hello humans
I eagerly await your excrement oh and
one more thing but why don't I let my
friend tell you about it please welcome
the president of unified Earth Brodie
sandals how's it going everyone
oh yeah I just want to say I love the
smart toilet so much and you know Anton
here is volunteer to have a boat shrine
installed in every home on the planet
for free so yeah not suspiciously
generous mr. president would you like to
christen the boltron no I don't mind if
I do brother Wow it even feels smart
haha now if you'll just press that
button while I stand very far away
Oh No who could have anticipated that
not me
[Music]
sorry grumps take that enjoy this
yes claiming see here I'm sorry sir is
this a bad time
not at all in turn Rachel just working
out something terrible has happened to
the president I'm sending you a video
now oh dear God
is he dead initializing Randy who's
Randy not who but what it's the world's
most advanced computer Randy are you
online amen
what's going on Randy do you know what
happened oh yeah definitely
okay will you tell me basically his
consciousness has been split across
three alternate dimensions each
dimension is a physical manifestation of
an aspect of the president's
consciousness trippy right this smells
like piss you Anton pissed the toilet
tycoon I never trusted him he's bald
we'll deal with pissed later but right
now we have to retrieve the president
piece by piece
how do we even do that there's no time
in this episode get my car ready and
Rachel we never really had a chance to
talk about what you hope to gain from
this internship thanks for asking
well right now I'm majoring in cash
let's go
if my calculations are correct which
they always are right now the flaming
sea is scouring the multiverse for the
president's consciousness time to
initiate phase two soon everyone is
going to tremble when they hear the name
Anton piss okay that's enough laughing
you